drivers will soon be able to use the
freeway HOV lanes in southern Nevada for
most of the day regardless of how many
people are inside the car thank you for
joining us here at four I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus ndot made
that decision this morning Ryan mathey
driving around right now tells us what
this means for the future of these buddy
Lanes here in Nevada Ryan
well Brian I'm not driving I'm being
passenger princess at the moment but
generally speaking let's talk about HOV
enforcement that used to be 24 7 in
Nevada but now the State Board of
transportation is limiting that even
further let's take a live look now at
one of the HOV lanes we're talking about
this one like here on the 95 there's
potential to get rid of these but it's
not without years more work
he would always see people with nobody
in the car Robbie Davis drives these
freeways daily but says the incentive of
driving in this Lane is not enough for
him to carpool you're not like hey let's
get three three of my neighbors on my
car so we can use the HOV lane that's I
don't see that that's not causing people
to drive less it's really causing people
to break the law the concerns of Nevada
lieutenant governor Steph Ross Anthony
who acknowledges single drivers
frequently hop into the lane even when
they're not supposed to project neon
brought a 24 7 HOV enforcement period
back in 2019 then just six months ago an
ndot pilot program eliminated overnight
enforcement if people were changing
their behavior and actually we were
reducing vehicles on the roadway through
the HOV lane system I would be all for
it but that's not happening he and the
rest of the State Transportation board
unanimously voted to alter those hours
Monday morning 6 a.m to 8 A.M and 4 pm
to 6 PM every weekday but potential
remains to get rid of them altogether
after a required environmental study
that could take up to 24 months the
board is moving forward with that study
as well now we're in a position to know
what the federal government wants
because these are technically Federal
highways
now those changes are expected within 30
days from today but new signs need to be
made with the new times on them coming
back to me live now the lieutenant
governor says for comparison purposes
when they made changes back in October
it took them just two nights to
implement all these changes once those
signs were made for now reporting live
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now